so our next speaker is jordan harbinger
he's the founder of the autocharm which
is an academy that teaches emotional
intelligence and confidence as a skill
and they actually do high seven figures
annually in revenue
and he's also the host of a radio show
that has close to a million monthly
listeners which is really really awesome
so jordan's gonna talk about some of the
things that he's learned during the art
of charm
all right hey guys i'm jordan harbinger
from the art of charm my company teaches
emotional intelligence elements of
confidence and relationship development
but i didn't always do this several
years ago i worked on wall street and i
was an attorney which is one of the most
boring jobs that probably a lot of you
can imagine
and i had a quote unquote mentor who i
never saw he was never in the office and
he was rumored to make more money than
every other attorney in the firm so
i knew something was up because he had a
great tan for a brooklyn boy and that's
there's that's not normal so one day he
took me out for coffee and i'm pretty
sure hr made him do it and he said ask
me anything and i said all right because
i didn't care about the job at the time
i said how come everyone says you make
more money than everyone else but you're
never in the office and after a long
awkward pause he told me that the reason
he was out of the office and the reason
the other lawyers were in the office at
one o'clock in the morning on a sunday
was because
they were just grinding away doing
technical work and he was out doing
important stuff like golfing
doing cruises and doing charity events
with other people that actually brought
business to the firm and so after i let
that sink in it changed the way that i
look at work forever because what that
essentially means is that your people
skills are going to trump your technical
skills no matter what if you're billing
hours and you're putting in tons of
technical know-how that's great but
somebody who can relate and bring in
relationships will always beat you in
terms of revenue and value to your
company so that of course prompted me to
ditch technical skills graduate from law
school mail it in for the bar exam
barely passing and focus on learning
people skills
for the rest of my life hopefully right
at least for the next few years and that
led to the art of charm and so
essentially what i realized through that
process is that people buy you they
don't buy your product they don't buy
your service they actually buy you
they're looking at the way that they
relate to you and if you look to the
left and you look to the right you'll
see people that are doing startups just
like you but people don't care about
that as a business owner and as a
consumer of any kind i know that i'm
just buying something because i like it
because i like dealing with the person
who sells it even with joel's buffer i
use that you know why i use it other
things probably do that but i like their
customer service i like joel and i like
what buffer does but in that order right
so i think in for my purposes what that
taught me is that buying is an emotional
process it's not a logical one and if
you don't believe me think about the
last time you bought clothes especially
if you're wearing a leopard skin suit or
red jeans with red shoes it's an
emotional decision it's not something
that you do because it's the best thing
to cover your body it's something you do
because it makes you feel a certain way
right exactly that's right so you do
that and if you know what that means for
you that means that your first
impression in the way that you carry
yourself is everything and of course
what that means for a lot of you is that
your first impression is something that
you think you make when you open your
mouth and that's not true your first
impression is made when other people
find you as a blip on their radar in
other words when they see you and you
can't talk to everyone at the same time
but what you do communicate with all the
time is your body and your nonverbal
communication
and so we need to make sure that that is
nailed all of the time no matter what
and the way that we're going to do that
is every single day every single minute
for the next two weeks every time you
walk through a door you're going to
straighten up with a string pulling up
from your head you're going to
straighten your back up and you're going
to push your chest out and put a smile
on your face and don't exaggerate it
you'll look ridiculous even more so than
the guy in the leopard skin suit who's
not here anymore but you'll look
ridiculous and so what you're going to
do is make sure that that changes your
physiology and that's going to change
your mindset because it's going to
change the way that people relate to you
and it's going to change the way that
you feel about yourself and of course
what we know from that once you get good
at that is you can start to change the
way that you make eye contact and a lot
of you if you're like me shake hands
like this or at least you used to and it
looks terrible and people notice that
and if you notice the eye color of
everyone that you speak with you're
going to start making better eye contact
with people and when you do that you're
going to start to see the anxiety melt
away and when the anxiety melts away
you're going to carry yourself and sell
yourself better than you ever have and
sell your product better than you ever
have because of course business to
business people buy you they don't buy
your product they don't buy your service
they buy your personal guarantee and
because they like trust and respect you
and business to business it's the same
thing it's because they like trust and
respect you and for first impressions
for most of us that means we need to
step our game up big time which is what
we do at the art of charm and as for
first impressions this is my first
impression for most of you i'm jordan
harbinger i hope this was a good one and
if it wasn't the most enlightening 4
minutes and 58 seconds of your life
sam's giving refunds in the back thank
you